der schnellste Jahresrückblick der Welt
teil 1 Hz 4 heißt jetzt Bürgergeld 502 €
Regelsatz oder wie man bei der FDP sagt
einmal lecker essen gehen die USA
schießen einen übergroßen chinesischen
beobachtungsballon ab mit einer Rakete
mit Kanonen auf Spatzen schießen ist so
2022 echte Männer ballern Raketen auf
Luftballons Frankreich erhöht das
Renteneintrittsalter französische
Wissenschaftler haben herausgefunden
dass die Arbeitsmoral ab 60 zwar abnimmt
aber dann ab 80 wieder rapide zunimmt
erste Pläne zur Legalisierung von
Cannabis die eigenbedarfsgrenze soll bei
25 g sein pro Person 25 g sind
Eigenbedarf ich habe es meinem
Schuldirektor immer gesagt späte
Genugtung für mich das 9 € Ticket da 49
€ 1 € pro durchschnittlicher
verspätungsminute Jackpot die Söldner
der wagnergruppe Wagen den Aufstand
gegen Moskau nach 36 Stunden sagt deren
Chef prigoschin war doch nicht so
gemeint warauf in Putin sagt ach ist
doch nicht schlimm Schwamm drüber
deswegen bringe ich dich doch nicht
gleich um also nicht gleich ein paar
Monate später stürzt prigosch ins
Flugzeug ab